>> Tucker: THERE ARE GOING TO
BE LIVE DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
SENATE RACE IN JUST A MOMENT,
BUT FIRST CANDACE OWENS RAISED A
RELEVANT QUESTION THE OTHER DAY
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS DO YOU
THINK THAT THE BOTOX FILLER FAKE
LIPS LOOK ATTRACTIVE?
THAT IS A REAL QUESTION BECAUSE
ALL OF A SUDDEN EVERYBODY IN
POWER HAS FAKE FACES, NANCY
PELOSI LOOKS LIKE MICHAEL
JACKSON.
NOT TO BE MEAN, BUT IT IS TRUE,
GRETCHEN WITMER TAKING HER BOTOX
AFLOAT AS WELL.
WHAT PART OF JOE BIDEN IS STILL
REAL?
WELL, JEFF BEZOS IS COMPLETELY
TRANSFORMED BY THE STUFF.
SO WITH CANDACE OWENS, WE
DECIDED TO ASK IF THIS IS A SIGN
OF SOMETHING DEEPER, A MORE DEEP
FAKENESS IMPACTING OUR
LEADERSHIP.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE MOST IMPORTANT TOPICS
OF LIFE, BUT THIS GOT A HUGE
RESPONSE.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> OH, MAN, I'M LAUGHING OUT
LOUD AT BOTOX-GATE, I CAN'T LOOK
AT NANCY'S EYES ANYMORE AND NOT
CHUCKLE.
TALKING ABOUT THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMMUNE SYSTEM, LOOKING AT ALL OF
THESE DIGITAL APPEARANCES, THE
BOTOX TOXINS, WE EMULATE WHAT WE
SEE, MASK SAVING LIVES, AND NOT
SENDING CHILDREN OUTSIDE.
EVERYBODY IS STARTING TO LOOK
THE SAME AND IT'S LIKE AN AVATAR
AND IT'S VERY BIZARRE.
WITH THOSE THAT WANT TO GET A
NIP AND TUCK, I DON'T PERSONALLY
DO IT, BUT I WAS CURIOUS IF MEN
FOUND THIS NEW PHASE TO BE
ATTRACTIVE AND BOY WAS I MET
WITH SO MUCH HEAT FROM WOMEN,
HAVE A CLOSE FRIEND THAT GETS
BOTOX THAT SAYS CANDACE, YOU ARE
LAUNCHING A WAR ON US WHITE
WOMEN, HOW DARE YOU, THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
I REALIZE THAT SOME TOPICS,
TUCKER, ARE TOO SENSITIVE, I
WOULD LIKE TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
FANS BECAUSE I WILL LEAVE YOUR
BOTOX AND FILLER ALONE, BUT WE
SHOULD INVESTIGATE WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT.
EVERYONE IS LOOKING THE SAME
NUMBER THAT IS AN INSIGHTFUL
OBSERVATION THAT HAS NEVER
OCCURRED TO ME.
I DON'T WANT TO BE JUDGMENTAL,
EVERYBODY DOES THEIR OWN THING
OR WHATEVER.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING A LITTLE
BIT AWFUL ABOUT THAT, IS THERE
NOT?
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT IS AWFUL
IS THAT MEN AGE LIKE FINE WINE,
MEN GET BETTER AS THEY AGE.
A MAN IN 20 YEARS OLD WILL NOT
LOOK AS GOOD AS 45 YEARS OLD.
IT IS BIZARRE THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO HOLD ONTO YOUTH.
INDIVIDUAL START TO GET GRAY
HAIR, YET THEY ARE BEING
IMPACTED BY THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMMUNE SYSTEM ON INSTAGRAM, AND
EVERYBODY LOOKS THE SAME ON
INSTAGRAM.
IT'S HARD TO TELL A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A TRANS MAN OR WOMAN WHO
HAS BEEN GETTING A LOT OF WORK.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE AT.
I WANTED TO OPEN THE
CONVERSATION AND SAY IT'S
POSSIBLE TO LIKE YOUR FACE AND
AGE GRACEFULLY.
I HAVE LEARNED THAT PEOPLE ARE
NOT READY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AS OF YET.
>> Tucker: I AGREE, I HAVE
NEVER GOTTEN A